morning gents my team made accounting
error but I think security should have
checked the infantry before the strip
search for the sake of my business I've
got to get the guys back on site and
that means facing up to our mistakes
right listen first of all yeah I'm gonna
apologize for the humiliation we didn't
lose a peeler yeah 11 came in we should
have double-checked anyone got anything
else to say about it yeah garlic
everything what you got dad take that
time that's done that's done all right
I'm depending on these guys to work
alongside me and after this [ __ ] up I
really owe them right Oh cut yourself we
need a money-making product that can
launch this business so while they carry
on learning with my assistant G I'm off
to test out some recipes
[Music]
I've got a hunch that combining some
childhood favorites of mine might just
give us the edge lemon curd for me
growing up and all that little bit
luxury and it tastes delicious
so first up a classic with a twist lemon
curd treacle tart Jamie in the other
yeah
carefully try that please okay why do I
wanna do the hard way and using the
lemon curd base again for a different
spin on a baked well it's kinda stuff
for me that I grew up with for mummies
to run a little tea house call the
cobweb tea house professionals and the
only thing I ever wanted was either
carrot cake bagel tart or treacle tart
it was so delicious it may work it may
not work it may be too lemony
you never know unless you try so thank
you - Carla's prawns bottom five burger
yes really how long for that child
the bakewell's not quite the unique
taste I'm looking for the product I feel
could have selling power is the lemon
treacle tart
[ __ ] delicious sorry lemon curd it's
because that double
double-double deliciousness I mean
honestly it's rich its creamy and it's
just wow that works
I think this tart is the kind of
standout product we need to build a
business on so today I'm taking my
biggest gamble yet I'm not only gonna
put the tart to the test so it's a
hundred little loaves cool cut them in
half as Scotland's a hundred I want to
take advantage of everything the boys
have learned to bake so far and sell it
all in bulk to the public
[Music]
it's gonna get fired up everything's got
to be full if all these ovens are full
in an hour's time no you know I'll feel
it more relaxed when you go buy this
it's for prisoners or shouldn't be given
a chance we've met now especially with
the crime rate learning supposedly is
good look right guys come around please
quickly come around come around listen
it'll be setting up an opening for the
first time yeah
a pop-up bakery everything we produce
today is gonna be sold to the public and
I need to leave here with a van full not
of prisoners but of tarts I'm serious I
need to get this stuff out of it we need
a catchy name for the shop take your pen
I'm thinking bad boys bakery what are
the lads think have at our tea party
it's a [ __ ] cake shop not and summers
made by hate MP Brixton inmate tarts
yeah Nick these I'll cut your [ __ ]
hands off boy bakers I love that idea or
bad boy bakery but this is no BS now we
are going out and we are facing the
British public and we are gonna be
telling them everything you buy here has
been made by prisoners okay so the bad
boys bakery is born